[Musik]
frauenministerin ernst danke dass sie
sich zeit nehmen für phoenix in diesen
tagen öffnet in vielen bundesländern wie
der schule sind sie sich als
bildungsministerin des landes
brandenburg aber auch als präsidentin
der kultusministerkonferenz sicher dass
das die richtige entscheidung ist das
heißt sicher ich bin überaus froh
darüber dass uns dieser schritt gelingt
denn wir haben natürlich mit großer
sorge auf den langen lockdown und die
schulschließung geschaut das ist ein
großes ereignis und großer eingriff in
die bildungsbiographie der kinder und
jugendlichen
und es ist uns sehr schwer gefallen die
schulen zu schließen im dezember wir
mussten uns dem beugen weil das
infektionsgeschehen uns das auch
vorgegeben hat das ist auch richtig
gewesen aber wir haben natürlich jetzt
einen ganz langen zeitraum gehabt wo die
schulen geschlossen waren und wir wissen
welche folgen das für kinder und
jugendliche hat und deshalb freuen wir
uns dass in den meisten bundesländern
die grundschule wieder öffnen
finden sie die ausgangslage jetzt so
sicher dass man es wieder machen kann
angesichts auch der mutation gerade hat
der bundesgesundheitsminister gesagt
dass gut 20 prozent mehr als 20 prozent
der viren durch die mutation verbreitet
werden und die gelten ja gemeinhin als
gefährlicher
die gelten als gefährlicher aber wir
haben inzwischen ihr umfangreiches
schutzkonzept nicht nur für die schulen
auch für die anderen gesellschaftlichen
bereiche entwickelt die schulen werden
die schülerinnen schüler werden im
wechsel unterricht unterrichtet dass das
ist es höchstens die hälfte der kinder
jeweils auch da es geht nur um die
grundschulen und das kann die abstände
eingehalten werden und überwiegend
werden auch masken getragen das heißt
wir haben ein ganz umfangreiches
schutzkonzept zur mutation selber
schauen wir in deutschland natürlich
jetzt darauf wie wir das interpretieren
greifen unsere schutzkonzepte auch bei
der mutation oder führt sie zu einem
beschleunigten infektionsgeschehen das
ist die frage die sich natürlich in den
nächsten tagen entscheidet aber es ist
kein grund die schuleröffnung jetzt
nicht zu machen
wir sind mit impfungen aus für lehrer
und lehrerinnen das ist ja einen
prüfauftrag der aus dem letzten
beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
kanzlerin hervor geht wir haben uns
darüber gefreut dass jetzt auch vor dem
hintergrund eines impfstoffs der
ausdrücklich für menschen unter 65
geeignet ist da vorgezogen wird
ich hoffe dass die prüfung zu einem
guten ergebnis führt und so dass die
kita erzieherin
die grundschullehrkräfte schneller
geimpft ein zusätzlicher guter schutz
sie haben den beschluss der
kultusministerkonferenz angesprochen von
anfang februar einen tag bevor
vor der letzten bundesländer runde hat
das ganze stattgefunden da ist die rede
von sie haben schon gesagt impfungen
mehr tests mehr mehr schulbussen auch
das hätte man doch alles schon viel
früher haben können
also die entwicklung der schnelltests
hat in den letzten monaten eine große
dynamik entfaltet das hätte man im
oktober nicht fordern können im
gegenteil wir sind im letzten jahr damit
konfrontiert gewesen dass wir nicht
ausreichend test hat nun das ist eine
klare priorisierung für medizinische
bereiche gegeben hat und so gut ist es
ja dass es jetzt viele test gibt und
darauf haben wir mit unseren beschlüssen
reagiert der beschluss jetzt ist ein
beschluss mit dem votum für eine öffnung
an den grundschulen und ich freue mich
dass das in deutschland auch so
umgesetzt wird
bildungspolitik die bildungspolitische
rennen auch die bildungspolitiker stehen
sehr in der kritik im vergangenen jahr
seid ihr die korona pandemie hier so
massiv ausgebrochen ist und bis heute
werden wird ihnen vorgeworfen
es gebe keine schlüssigen konzepte für
digital beziehungsweise wechsel
unterricht statt dessen einen wust aus
teilöffnung weil jedes land ja jetzt
wieder anders erklären kann was ist dran
an diesen vorwürfen an dieser kritik
es ist in der tat so wir haben die
digitalisierung an den schulen in
deutschland in den letzten acht bis zehn
jahren nicht schnell genug voran
getrieben daraus eine kritik der
aktuellen kmk abzuleiten halte ich für
unseriös ich glaube da müssen sich ein
paar mehr an die nase fassen und zu
sagen das war nicht gut das haben wir in
deutschland nicht gut gemacht wir sind
aber in der aufholjagd gut war dass wir
im bund länder den digital park ergänzt
haben um dinge die wir jetzt sehr
schnell brauchen und das sind die
endgeräte für die schülerinnen und
schüler
ich wünsche mir auch dass das schneller
geht das sage ich ihnen aber es sind die
ersten geräte da wir haben das thema
systemadministration durch eine bund
länder vereinbarung auf den weg gebracht
und auch die endgeräte für lehrkräfte
und wie gesagt das sind große schritte
die hätte man fünf jahre vorher machen
können aber man holt nicht in neun
monaten auf was acht bis zehn jahre
vorher versäumt wurde welche rolle
spielt die kultusministerkonferenz im
hinblick auf das was bund und länder bei
ihren spezial runden die ja aber erst in
zwei bis drei wochen takt im moment
stattfinden
wir hoffen eine gute rolle eine
beratende rolle wir verstehen uns als
kultusminister kultusminister natürlich
auch
als welche die unsere
ministerpräsidenten beraten die ihr zu
der konferenz fahren aber es hat sich im
moment ein bisschen so eingespielt dass
die kmk vorher tag und meine wahrnehmung
ist dass die beschlüsse der
kultusministerkonferenz eine
aufmerksamkeit genießen wie es in den
letzten jahren nicht wahr und das
spricht ja für die kmk dass das was wir
sagen auch gehört wird und letztlich der
eröffnungsbeschluss jetzt eben als sich
auch in die praxis umgesetzt habe und
trotzdem haben sie in der vergangenheit
viele länder immer sehr individuell
gelöst und geregelt ja aber
ehrlicherweise jetzt wird immer der
bildungsföderalismus kritisiert da ist
aber der gehört aber zu unserem
gemeinwesen und ich sage es sehr gerne
noch mal wir haben eine bundestagswahl
und wir haben sechs landtagswahlen und
wer politisch am bildungsföderalismus
was ändern will
das soll das dort einbringen wo die
wählerinnen und wähler auch entscheiden
ich finde es macht keinen sinn immer
wenn irgendwo etwas nicht passt oder
einfach nicht gefällt oder an die
lernplattform nicht gefällt oder man
sich über ein lehrer ärgert sagt man der
bildungsföderalismus sei schuld das
finde ich es stimmt es nicht weil eben
gerade vor ort auch die entscheidung gut
getroffen werden und wir auch vor ort
die möglichkeit haben mit allen an
schule beteiligten das sind ja viele im
dialog zu treffen die entscheidungen
vorzubereiten
das wage ich doch zu bezweifeln dass sie
das bei bundespolitischen vorgehen so
gut hinkriegen aber ich hätte gerne
konkrete und ich immer diese pauschale
verurteilung
es gab einen impf gipfel es gab einen
wirtschaftsgipfel warum gab es bislang
auch keinen bildungsgipfel
ich würde mal sagen weil die
kultusministerkonferenz gute arbeit
leistet und wie sieht der betrieb an
schulen aus in ungefähr einem jahr wohl
wissend dass coop 19 dann wahrscheinlich
noch nicht ganz ausgemacht sein wird ja
das ist eine ganz spannende frage ist
nur ist es schön dass man auch wieder
die gedanken etwas in die ferne
gerichtet und sich darauf einstellt ich
bin davon überzeugt dass hygieneregeln
eine große rolle spielen werden das
betrifft ja nicht nur kopf 19 sondern es
wird auch bei den erkältungskrankheiten
sicher der distanz unterricht wird eine
größere rolle spielen weil wir gelernt
haben dass schülerinnen und schüler sehr
gut sehr eigenverantwortlich arbeiten
können und dort auch lernfortschritte
machen aber nicht als einziges angebot
und ich hoffe es gibt kein zweifel daran
dass die große anstrengung die wir
brauchen um die schulen digital auf die
zukunft vorzubereiten dass die nicht
nachlässt so dass wir natürlich erwarten
dass der digital
keine eintagsfliege braucht und dass wir
alle gemeinsam helfen bund länder
kommunen die schulträger dass die
schulen gut aufgestellt sind und unsere
kinder und jugendlichen auch die
kompetenzen die sie bekommen um für die
nächsten jahrzehnte auch fürs leben in
der globalisierten welt gerüstet zu sein
frau ministeriums damit die vielen dank
für ihre zeit ich danke ihnen